[Music]
when you're a kid you'll always be
protected cared for be like hanging with
you thanks shouldn't think is too much
hanging out with us makes you a loser
too but when you're alone as a kid the
monster she was weaker
you don't even know they're getting
closer until it's too late
what where's the poison ivy nowhere okay
well I'm starting to get cheap and I'm
pretty sure this is not the same
bathroom as your mother sometimes yeah
then you probably have crabs so not
funny are cheaters coming in ah spray
water what the hell is grey water
it's basically piss and [ __ ] so I'm just
telling you you guys are splashing
around in millions of gallons of dairy
pee so what are you are you serious wait
doesn't smell my [ __ ] [ __ ] donation you
have you ever heard of a staph infection
also so unsanitary
you're literally this is blue aura
coming inside of a toilet bowl right now
you're the reason why we're in this
position my daughter whose sneaker is it
it's Betty Rubble oops what if she's
still here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]